>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER KARL SOB
TONIGHT.
WE BEGIN THIS SHOW WITH
SHOCKING NEWS, LYING HAS
BEEN DETECTED HERE IN
WASHINGTON.
MENDACITY, DECEIT, DO YOU DO YOU
PLIEWS TISNESS.
IT HAPPENED WE CAN PROVE IT
TO BE CLEAR, NEWS ANCHORS
DIDN’T DO IT.
NEWS ANCHORS DON’T LIE.
THEY ARE GOOD PEOPLE.
NEITHER DO PROFESSIONAL NEWS
COMMENTATORS THE ONES MAKING
MILLIONS ON THE SIDE AS
LOBBYISTS FOR FOREIGN
GOVERNMENTS OR BIG NATIONAL
CORPORATIONS.
COMMENTATORS ALWAYS TELL THE
TRUTH.
AND THAT’S WHY THEY, AND
THEIR SCRUPULOUSLY HONEST
NEWS ANCHOR FRIENDS ARE SO
HONESTLY DISGUSTED TONIGHT,
HORRIFIED REALLY BY WHAT
RETIRED GENERAL MICHAEL
FLYNN HAS DONE.
WATCH THEIR STUNNED
REACTION.
>> MICHAEL FLYNN LIED TO THE
FBI.
FLYNN LIED AGAIN AND AGAIN
AND AGAIN TO FBI AGENTS.
JUST LIED.
LIES, LIES, AND MORE LIES.
>> HOLD ON FOR JUST A MINUTE
ABOUT WHO IS SIGNIFICANT AND
WHO IS NOT.
FLYNN LIED, THE TONE SHOULD
BE WHEN YOU SPEAK TO A
PROSECUTOR, YOU SPEAK TO THE
TRUTH.
EVERYBODY LIED.
>> MICHAEL FLYNN WAS
BETRAYING HIS COUNTRY.
MICHAEL FLYNN WAS BETRAYING
HIS OFFICE.
>> Tucker: HE LIED SAYS
LEMON AND HIS NEWS ANCHOR.
LIED LIED LIED LYING KIND OF
MAN.
THE WORST KIND.
HE COULD NEVER WORK IN
TELEVISION.
FOR HIS CRIME OF LYING,
MICHAEL FLYNN, THE LIAR, MAY
SOON BE LOCKED AWAY IN A
CELL.
THAT WOULD KEEP THE REST OF
US SAFE FROM HIS LIES THAT
DAY CAN’T COME FAST ENOUGH
SAY THE NEWS ANCHORS.
CUFF HIM AMERICA LONGS TO
BREATHE FREE ONCE MORE.
MICHAEL FLYNN WILL BE 60
YEARS OLD NEXT WEEK, "THE
WASHINGTON POST" CALCULATES
HE FACES FIVE YEARS IN
PRISON AND LET THAT BE A
WARNING TO ALL OF US.
THAT’S WHAT HAPPENS TO
PEOPLE WHO LIE IN
WASHINGTON.
OR DOES IT?
FROM A GOLF COURSE SOMEWHERE
IN DUBAI YOU CAN ALMOST HEAR
BILL CLINTON CHUCKLING
SOFTLY LIED UNDER OATH STILL
MAKING 300 GRAND A SPEECH.
HA HA HA.
NOT EVERYONE FACES THE SAME
PENALTIES FOR LYING IT TURNS
OUT.
MARK ZUCKERBERG CAME TO
WASHINGTON LAST SPRING TO
TALK ABOUT FACEBOOK THE SOLE
DESTROYING SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANY MADE HIM A
MULTIBILLIONAIRE.
ZUCKERBERG STOPPED BY THE
CONGRESS WHERE YOU MIGHT
WANT TO ASK THE KIDS TO
LEAVE THE ROOM FOR THIS HE
LIED.
DON’T TELL DON LEMON MARK
ZUCKERBERG IS A LIAR.
WATCH HIM DO THIS.
>> THIS IS THE MOST
PRINCIPLE FOR FACEBOOK.
EVERY PIECE OF CONTENT THAT
YOU SHARE ON FACEBOOK, YOU
OWN AND YOU HAVE COMPLETE
CONTROL OVER WHO SEES IT AND
HOW YOU SHARE IT.
AND YOU CAN REMOVE IT AT ANY
TIME.
>> ARE YOU WILLING TO GIVE
ME MORE CONTROL OVER MY
DATA?
>> SENATOR, AS SOMEBODY WHO
USES FACEBOOK I BELIEVE YOU
SHOULD HAVE COMPLETE CONTROL
OVER YOUR DATA.
>> Tucker: YEAH, HAVE YOU
COMPLETE CONTROL OVER YOUR
DATA.
YOU CONTROL WHO SEES IT.
YOU OWN IT THAT’S REALLY THE
MOST IMPORTANT PRINCIPLE AT
FACEBOOK.
MARK ZUCKERBERG SAYS SO WITH
A COMPLETELY STRAIGHT FACE.
THE ONLY PROBLEM IT WAS A
LIE.
SORRY, KIDS.
ACCORDING TO A PIECE IN THE
"NEW YORK TIMES," FACEBOOK
DOES NOT ACTUALLY ALLOW YOU
OR ANYONE TOLLS CONTROL YOUR
DATA.
NOT AT ALL.
IN FACT, THEY SECRETLY HAND
OVER YOUR DATA PERSONAL DATA
TO OTHER BIG TECH COMPANIES.
NOW, THAT DECISION HAS MADE
MARK ZUCKERBERG EVEN RICHER,
ADDING ON THE HOUSE IN
HAWAII, PROBABLY.
UNFORTUNATELY, HE HAS HAD TO
LIE IN THE PROCESS.
, INCLUDING TO CONGRESS AND
THAT’S A CRIME.
AS ROB SPHERE ONCE FAMOUSLY
NOTED YOU CAN’T BREAK AN
OMELET WITHOUT BREAKING A
FEW EGGS.
IN THIS CASE THE EGGS ARE
YOUR PRIVACY.
APPARENTLY MICROSOFT ALLOWED
BINGE TO SEE THE NAMES OF
YOUR FACEBOOK FRIENDS
WITHOUT TELLING YOU ABOUT IT
NETFLIX AND SPOTIFY TO READ
YOUR PRIVATE MESSAGES
WITHOUT TELLING YOU.
NOW, THERE IS NO EVIDENCE SO
FAR AS OF TONIGHT THAT
FACEBOOK HAS A VIDEO CAMERA
HIDDEN IN YOUR SHOWER.
BUT CLOSE ENOUGH.
THAT’S WHAT MARK ZUCKERBERG
LIED ABOUT.
NOT A SMALL LIE, REALLY.
WHAT DID MIKE FLYNN LIE
ABOUT?
WELL, ACCORDING TO THE FBI.
FLYNN LIED ABOUT
CONVERSATIONS HE HAD HAD
WITH THE RUSSIAN AMBASSADOR
KISLYAK.
YOU REMEMBER HIM.
FLYNN SAID THAT HE AND
KISLYAK HAD NEVER TALKED
ABOUT EXPELLING RUSSIAN
DIPLOMATS OR ABOUT RUSSIA
VOTING IN THE U.N. ON
SYMBOLIC RESOLUTIONS.
AND IN FACT THEY HAD TALKED
ABOUT BOTH OF THOSE THINGS.
THE FEDS ALREADY KNEW THAT
BECAUSE THEY WERE LISTENING
IN SECRETLY.
THERE WAS NOTHING IMPROPER
ABOUT THE CONVERSATIONS THAT
FLYNN AND KISLYAK HAD.
THE CRIME WAS THE LIE.
IT’S ALWAYS THE CRIME.
EXCEPT WHEN IT’S MARK
ZUCKERBERG.
MARK ZUCKERBERG CAN LIE
ABOUT SOMETHING THAT EFFECTS
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS BUT IT’S NOT
REALLY A BIG DEAL.
ZUCKERBERG IS NOT LOOKING AT
FIVE YEARS IN PRISON.
ZUCKERBERG WILL NOT BE
SANCTIONED BY CONGRESS EVER.
SO WHAT’S THE DIFFERENCE?
WELL, UNLIKE MIKE FLYNN,
MARK ZUCKERBERG IS A HERO TO
THE AMERICAN NEWS MEDIA.
HE IS WHO THEY WANT TO BE.
HE IS RICHER THAN GOD.
HE WENT TO HARVARD.
HE WEARS T-SHIRTS AT WORK
FOR REAL IS HE FOR OPEN
BORDERS.
ALL THE COOL PEOPLE LIKE
MARK ZUCKERBERG.
EVEN FOREIGN COUNTRIES.
FOR EXAMPLE, IN THE FASCIST
GOVERNMENT OF CHINA WAS
LOOKING FOR NEW TOOLS TO
OPPRESS ITS OWN POPULATION,
YOU THINK THEY WENT TO MIKE
FLYNN FOR HELP?
OKAY.
I DON’T THINK SO.
FLYNN IS TOUGH ON CHINA, OLD
FASHIONED AS HE IS.
BUT MARK ZUCKERBERG BY
CONTRAST WAS HAPPY TO HELP.
AS THEY SAY AT THAT
AS THEY SAY AT MAMMA KEN IS
I MARK ZUCKERBERG.
33 YEARS IN UNIFORM THAT’S
NOT VERY INNOVATIVE.
TWO LIES TOLD BY TWO HIGH
PROFILE AMERICANS.
ONE IS GOING TO PRISON IN
LATE MIDDLE AGE.
THE OTHER WILL BE AVAILABLE
FOR LIKE 40 YEARS FOR
COMMENCEMENT ADDRESSES AND
AWARD DINNERS HELD IN HIS
HONOR.